there was a whole bunch of good news
yesterday and i know it's a little hard
to find the good news you got to wade
through stuff and you got to kind of
really look for it sometimes but there
really was some great news yesterday the
supreme court blocked the biden
administration's osha vaccine mandate
we've got some info on that from the
daily wire on thursday the supreme court
blocked a biden administration mandate
that would have forced private
businesses with at least 100 employees
to require workers to be vaccinated
against covet 19 or submit to regular
testing okay so this has been one of the
big ones that everybody's been fighting
about as you know the daily wire
themselves led by jeremy boring and ben
shapiro and the other guys
they were one of the companies fighting
this harmeet dillon my friend who's been
on the show she was one of the leading
lawyers on the case and this is this is
great news it got all the way up to the
supreme court and in my humble
estimation the supreme court did make
the right decision now i can't tell you
that it was all perfect yesterday
because the other decision that the
supreme court made was that the mandate
on health care workers would stand and
believe it or not brett kavanaugh
was the deciding vote on that he voted
saying that it would stand for health
care workers now i i'm not going to sit
here and pretend that i am a
constitutional scholar i have some
pretty pretty good knowledge of some of
this stuff it seems a little bit weird
i'm going to try to read it later when
i'm in the car i'll read uh his
commentary on it it seems a little odd
to me if you say oh it is
unconstitutional
for private companies to force people to
be vaccinated that but it is
constitutional for health care companies
to do it it's like i don't know how that
fits into the constitution that
depending on the type of work that you
do now there may be some minutia and
details in there that we can we can go
through so we'll see a little bit more
about that but in essence
this idea that these companies with at
least 100 employees are not going to be
forced to do anything they don't want to
do which by the way kicks the choice
back to the individual right it makes
you make a choice for yourself i would
like to be vaccinated i will go to work
or perhaps i can talk to my boss about
working from home if other people aren't
vaccinated and i'm worried about that
that's the messiness of freedom it's the
beauty of freedom rather than top-down
government you must do this to work here
i don't have a hundred employees but i
know i know in my bones i have no right
whether i have 10 employees or 100
employees to say to people who work for
me who are not my slaves they work for
me in an open and honest free exchange i
have no right to say them you must get
injected with this thing to work for me
so this was good this was this was
really really good and it's just another
marker and i know it's hard to see guys
as i said before you've got to kind of
look through the brush but it's just
another marker that things are turning a
little bit the biden
approval rating that we talked about
yesterday at 33 percent the glen younkin
win in virginia which is a big hit on
critical race theory the fact that
people are going
showing up to stores and seeing the
supply chain stuff and going oh maybe
that does have something to do with the
policies of this government or when we
see 9.7
inflation and you go oh again maybe this
has something to do with the policies
like people are waking up when you see
people going over the last couple weeks
hey i didn't get vaccinated i got
covered that guy did get vaccinated he
got covered we all kind of it all kind
of shook out the same maybe i'm allowed
to ask some questions
yeah you know what it's still america
and you're still allowed to ask some
questions